this morning local businesses came
together for an event showcase it's all
to network and highlight the services
available for business owners mary jane
belliesa shares why the community's
support means more amount more now than
ever
over 50 local businesses were in
attendance at the clark county
amphitheater for small business saturday
with the goal of supporting local
business owners and increasing their
opportunities for success chantal de
laurentii owns a taste of coffee she
says it's not only important to receive
community support but for other
businesses to support each other we
wouldn't be here without our locals and
so one of the things that we give back
to is we have baked goods that we
actually bring in small local businesses
one example is we have the aussie
projects that they actually make
australian meat pies in which we're
really super excited because they are
actually going to start having them in
store aussie project restaurant owner
alex biffin says partnerships like these
is a good way to reach new patrons and
make connections i've actually just
joined a group it's a bni business group
and their main their whole outlook on on
business is helping each other out and
i've sort of just really adopted that i
really love that i just love the
camaraderie and the community spirit
christina amos owner of bella natural
says while she was lucky to have built a
base of loyal customers prior to the
pandemic she knows not everyone is as
lucky so those customers kept me alive
and that was so important for me
in colton during colby times and that's
why another reason why it's so important
for the community support our small
businesses because you keep us alive
mary jane ballaza live